attention interview à chaque dame
[Musique]
josiane balasko quel défaut doit avoir
un homme pour vous séduire
à part le breillat pis main qui
rappelons le est une maladie pas un
défaut un bon lavage et toi c'est toi
c'est un moyen non mais aussi des médias
mais aussi que tu a déniché 100 jours
d'intervalle et violente qu'à défaut
d'avoir un homme pourrait séduire
avant d'être un peu fragile voilà quelle
est l'insulté qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir
je suis très très vulgaire lé phénomène
allemand vulgaire quel est le con
c'était quoi je suis sûr c'est que ça
donne vraiment une insulte non mais
emmanuel je suis sûr que tu fais plaisir
concernant [ __ ] qui se baignait
enfin
mais ce ne sont pas choqués par la tenue
mais par l'horaire c'est beaucoup trop
tôt quel est le compliment qui vous
énerve le plus jamais de mémoire
phénoménale
si on est toujours mais comment ils font
pour apprendre tout ça quelle mémoire
quelle mémoire oui moi si vous quand je
vais voir des comédiens sur scène au
théâtre je leur dis mais comment vous
faites pour apprendre tout ce à quoi je
sais qu est ce que vous voudriez que vos
enfants ratent leur battre ça m'est égal
je mentais leur bac - contraire de toi à
non non non non ils poseront leurs tests
hiv sait bien que leur interdisez vous à
vos enfants que vous ne vous interdisez
pas qu'on était plus petit dire deux
mots grossiers
moi j'avais droit parle les pétards
aussi j'imagine c'est difficile enfin
toujours dans les temps n'est pas
toujours derrière parce qu'on verra si
il fait me viennent pas le faire sous
votre nez c'est vrai
pour quelles raisons seriez vous capable
de refuser votre plus belle histoire
d'amour pour des raisons fiscales
quel est le film à succès que vous êtes
content d'avoir refusé je compatis à 6
ici sinon mais j'aimerais dire j'ai pas
refusé de filmer les lundis celui auquel
tu pensais quand tu as des cheveux pas
le dire non non non je m'habille ya
prescription maintenant je sais pas quoi
tu pensais encore un coupera pas un
montage en son nom mais en plus j'ai pas
vu non non je peux pas dire tellement
raison que j'ai pas j'ai pas vu et des
films que je refuse que j'ai pas
forcément voir mais dans le mien par
exemple un nom le tiens j'ai me tue m'a
même pas tu m'as demandé mais j'étais en
train de bosser but insiste pas le
problème de la france c'est qui
n'insiste pas tweet à ses fans pour les
anciens
ben oui toi hills un site insiste
patanok je ne veux pas là il va pas
réduire il faut insister dans ce métier
si tu veux réussir ouais t'as essayé de
coucher
non non mais c'est bien longtemps sinon
si au début
au début tu coucher quand ouais ouais
j'ai arrêté toujours de dos c'est chiant
je vois pas les gens
telle est la question que je vous pose
ça vous fait a fait dix minutes que vous
posez des questions qu'il faudrait pas
bon
on passe maintenant donc à l'interview
de la vraie emmanuelle béart
c'est l'interview en salle d'armes
[Musique]
non personne n'à connais ça paraît un
peu aidés oui emmanuelle béart quel
défaut doit avoir un homme pour vous
séduire tous quelle est l'insulté qui
vous a fait le plus plaisir des horreurs
qu'il n'y en a plus sa confiance sinon
quel compliment qui vous énerve le plus
aucun compliment mais les menhirs pas
bon donc quand on vous dit que vous êtes
très belle en couverture de elle en fait
ça très bien
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que vos
enfants rate attendent pas leur bac en
tout cas pas leur vie non je voudrais
que tu attends je sais pas c'est bizarre
comme question à ses membres à ton nom
c'est mon mais justement huawei
qu'est ce qui vous a bien compris la
perversité de cet intérieur
le le magma firat le conservatoire voilà
voilà qui ratent leur première cigarette
qui rate voilà plein de trucs
qu'est-ce que vous interdisez à vos
enfants que vous ne vous interdisez pas
à vous même c'est comme l'autre c'est
comme notre question quelque 200 oeuvres
qui me donne pas dans un très mauvais
c'est tout ce que tous non je ne sais
pas je suis pas dans l'interdiction jeu
c'est pas comme ça qu'on pour quelles
raisons seriez vous capable de refuser
votre plus belle histoire d'amour
je ne refuserai jamais ma plus belle
histoire d'amour mais je suis devant du
célé pas derrière quel est le talent que
vous n'aimeriez pas avoir le talent que
je n'aimerais pas voir mais c'est une
drôle de truc
pardon talon d'achille allez montez
montez je suis monteur oui c'est vrai il
j'en ai fait mon métier donc voleuse
aussi on en un jour ni de volvo voulait
souhaite arriver mais ne trouve pas
grave non quand même rapport de police
détonnant des petits trucs
juste avant vous n'aimeriez pas marche
pas dissimulatrice ou non non non ça
j'aime bien tout ça ouais perverse wayne
toussaint perverse et non à chaud ben
sinon haslam
même si pas un talent les snobs noms me
viennent pour une autre interview n'en
fait rien on va finir celle là déjà tu
finis ton assiette
non alors en fait on va faire tous
appelé manuel
quel est le film à succès que vous êtes
contente d'avoir refusé mais j'ai jamais
refusé un film qui a eu du succès ouais
quel est le bide auquel vous êtes
contente d'avoir participé
le dernier film de rivette un régime
bien par qui a marié vous est détesté
par plein de gens qui meurent je suis
nom par nom même je parle parfois pas
par part qu il faut j'ai choisi ce
quelqu'un tu as dû ranger à marans des
sports
par sarkozy ah oui par qui n'habitent
pas le 11e rang valable quelle est la
question qu il ne faut pas que je vous
pose
non non toutes les questions sont
valables c'est vrai moi mais c'est avec
le temps il n'y a plus de question qu'on
peut non pas difficile tervueren
horrible vous avez bien sorties n'ont
pas dit ou s'ils voient alors la semaine
dernière on a fait une nouvelle
interview qu'on a testé sur emmanuelle
béart et josiane balasko une interview
impossible ça s'appelle l'interview ben
saïda
voici donc l'interview et saïda le
retour
[Musique]
jean luc lemoine quels sont les défauts
que doit avoir une femme pour vous
séduire défaut
beaucoup de mauvais esprit une poitrine
un peu trop grosse à l'acide qui vous a
fait le plus plaisir
il ya trois jours j'étais en spectacle
et pendant que je jouais ya quelqu'un
qui a dit dans la salle il est horrible
il est horrible ça ça me fait plaisir
parce qu'elle a rigolé après la personne
ouais bon si c'était sur mon physique ça
fait de la peine mais si c'était pour le
spectacle ça me fait plaisir
le compliment qui vous énerve le plus
c'est quand les gens disent dans la rue
à je vous adore
franchement je trouve aussi drôle que
gérard muller ça m'énerve
vous avez des enfants non j'en ai pas
quand vous en aurez qu est ce que vous
aimeriez qu'il rate le concours d'entrée
à popstars
que leur interdire y est vous que vous
ne vous interdis sied pas à vous même du
coucher avec ma femme
pour quelles raisons
seriez vous capable de refuser votre
plus belle histoire d'amour parce que ça
craint je vais quand même pas me marier
avec ma mère un jeu quel est le talent
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir de super
bien préparé les tripes c'est ça je m'en
fous un petit peu donc non ça ça
m'intéresse pas vraiment quelle est la
place de votre spectacle vous fait pas
rire c'est celle qu'on a vue dans
l'extrait sur les petits enfants qui
préparent enfin les pays asiatiques qui
préparent des métaux scop et des baskets
la blague me fait rire mais le font pas
du tout oui par qui m l'auriez-vous être
détesté par le mec de liv tyler
ah ouais j'aimerais bien qu'ils me
déteste et qu'il ait des raisons me
détester quelle phrase ne dites-vous
jamais tient aujourd'hui j'ai très bien
disque delory
attend il a édulcoré le propos est à
changer le nom parce qu'elle est là qu
est ce que vous aimeriez qu'on vous
volent aparté lice de sébastien j'ai un
peu de sérieusement qui m'a offert ainsi
en porcelaine à noël un jardin comme le
vol avant que loquace quelques mythes
marianne drôle george bush
qu'avez-vous fait délibérément à votre
insu alors là j'ai délibérément pas
compris la question là bas je crois pas
que vous voulez en dépend natacha bas
tout ce que ma conscience m'interdirais
à et voilà c'est fait avoir encore par
une fille du nouveau-brunswick
[Applaudissements]
jean lui
et quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait à une fois
j'ai un type qui est sortie du spectacle
en plein milieu du spectacle il a vu mon
équipe et leur a dit c'est honteux
autant de cynisme sa cause de spectacle
comme ça qu'il ya guère moi j'ai trouvé
ça un peu excessive et le pressage des
pôles terrestres
la dernière question qu'il faut pas que
je vous pose
et sinon à quel âge s'était fait reculer
tu sais pas si c'est pas une tare c'est
du bidon pour lui une interview au
standaard
[Musique]
la période saydon c'est la plus
difficile quels sont les défauts nicola
sirkis que doit avoir une femme pour
vous séduire une vaginite aiguë avec
pertes blanches prochaine sur les
inconnues ça serait bien mais que la wii
pour les inconnus ça serait bien mal
l'insultent qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir
si c'est une insulte sur eux on compte
dix mois [ __ ]
ah oui ça me fait plaisir vas-y francky
téléphone ouais non sa note nicolas le
compliment qui vous énerve le plus il
est trop gentil où il est gentil
ouais mais c'est vrai que des gens qui
en même temps je sais non mais c'est
vrai que les gens mais je sais moi je la
rencontre et l'autre soir chez moi un
truc madrid est chiant quand il est pas
gentil il est patient c'est pas pareil
c'était pour sa fille il voulait un
autographe pour pas de lampard pour sa
fille parce que sa fille n'aime pas
indochine en france est mauvaise les
galas qui pourrait être sa fille la
fille mm
voilà mais elle a eu sa période mais son
petit ami m indochine ans un copain
elle m'a dit que c'était surtout ses
petites amies à arriver rich
suzanne jeu sera plus tranquille alors
nicolas le conseil de nos parents qui ne
fallait pas suivre fait confiance aux
grandes personnes
le disque que vous avez honte d'avoir
acheté ou alors c'est pas contre la
chanson 1
mais ni l'artiste c'est lolita d'alizée
mais en fait c'est parce que je voulais
le reprendre on voulait reprendre la
chanson moi je voulais la faire à ma
façon je m'appelle nicolas et nice et au
est là mais ça le groupe sa a pas plu du
tout du tout le butin non saisie des
donc j'ai eu l'idée que vous aimeriez
qu'on vous vole une idée fixe
ouais une obsession ouais pour quelles
raisons seriez vous capable de refuser
votre plus belle histoire d'amour bas
que ce soit la femme de mon meilleur ami
rudy par exemple ouais tu vas lui c'est
après pas la femme de son meilleur ami
je me suis excusé pour ta femme c'est
bon le talent que vous ne riez pas avoir
nicolas videur dans une boîte échangiste
ce qu'il est léger retard aussi la
mauvaise sans que vous auriez aimé
chanter à pas mal la chanson populaire
que vous êtes fier de ne pas avoir
chanté par principe un hymne national
ouais et parfois de leurs principales
stars principe nicholas pard qui
aimeriez-vous être détesté 3 par des
vieux cons voir des jeunes cons comment
il nous parle
la dernière question qu'il ne faut pas
que je vous pose est-ce que ça va voilà
mais c'est une question à l'époque je
vous la pose et voilà ça reste à lyon ça
va vous faire la pub l'interview premier
dans cette émission c'est l'interview
habsheim d'armes
attention se concentre expression
frédéric qu elle l insulte qui vous a
fait le plus plaisir
ah oui c'est donc c'est un interview
compliqué
on me traite souvent ou et de non
écrivain mondain ouais en fait ça fait
plaisir parce que c'est ce qu'on disait
à proust à cocteau a feature alors
qu'elle est le compliment qui vous
énerve le plus dans la rue quelquefois
il ya des gens qui disent et canal+ je
t'adore
comment tu t'appelles ça ça n'est jamais
venu pour quelles raisons seriez vous
capable de refuser votre plus belle
histoire d'amour frédéric j'ai pas si la
fille de montereau trop cher oui quels
sont les défauts quels sont les défauts
que doit avoir une femme pour vous
séduire
j'ai pas être aveugle
infoman à la femme un infirmier part dès
9 heures ce n'est pas vrai
malheureusement par qui aimeriez-vous
être détesté
alors bon il y en a déjà plein 1 mais
c'est vrai que j'aimerais bien être
détesté par norman mélo tom wolfe qui
soit fou de jalousie devant l'évidence
grand talent au bac
sauf qu'ils savent pas ils connaissent
même pas mon existence nous on connaît
merci c'est gentil chez soi c'est très
simple mais enlève le journal que vous
avez honte de lui à frédéric il ya
interconnexion connaissais pas ça c'est
le magazine de la sexualité récréative
depuis longtemps ça va et tu le lis mais
pas dans le train fera vraiment quel est
le salaire que vous n'avez pas mérité ah
ben
canal+ à partir de mon licenciement en
novembre 2002 eu un parachute
voilà jusqu'en juin 2003 j'étais payé à
ne rien [ __ ]
ah oui tu as pris combien donc c'était
c'était chez plus j'étais coproducteur
enfants parce que moi en euros du genre
150 mille francs par mois
partout mais c'est bien par rapport à
emmanuel 50 c'est horrible je sais
j'aurais honte de quel crime voudriez
vous qu'on vous accuse
c'est vrai qu'il est très très dur cette
interview je tiens à dire que c'est
parce que vous avez un céline qui
l'aurait fait signe vers le toit alors à
un crime de lèse majesté flèches bien
par quelle maladie voudriez vous êtes
sûrs après quoi un crime de lèse majesté
de faire ça quand il enchaîne sur la
question voilà voilà
par quelle maladie voudriez vous être
frappé par la modestie le priapisme oui
les blagues sexuelles se marchent
toujours moi c'est un marché sur moi
mais la moyen ne déride bbk interdisez
vous à vos enfants que vous faites vous
même du skate
[Musique]
13h04 je ne suis pas loin la drogue pour
sénart il faut préciser que ma fille à 5
m et le talent que vous n'aimeriez pas
avoir frédéric je n'aimerais pas avoir
lâché pas le talent de marc lévy ou
christine orban
quel est le mauvais film que vous auriez
aimé créer enfin d'eric le mauvais trip
que j'aurais aimé écrire à part
non non en double zéro c'est très très
bien merci pour lui j'aime penser très
drôles j'adore jeu j'en parle d'autant
mieux je n'ai pas vu mais je pense que
c'est très bien c'est génial non un
mauvais film que j'aime écrire c'est on
se calme et on boit frais à saint tropez
à frédéric sens qu'elle est la dernière
question qu'il ne faut pas que je vous
pose
je sais pas mais je suis content parce
que pour l'instant vous ne m'avez pas
demander est ce que ça me faisait que
houellebecq soit parti de chez
flammarion
ça vous fait quoi que c'était sûr c'est
bon ça l'impôt sérieuses à classer au
cul menway mal au cul voilà
mais un jour il reviendra et je lui
dirai aux la pomponnette revient
bienvenus tu peux revenir qu'à voulu
voir du pays et je voyais qu'il fallait
pas me la poser
et
[Musique]
alors passé les gens de révoquer on a
une interview ici pour les gens
compliqué qui marche à tous les coups
c'est l'interview woodside d'art qu'est
ce qu'on peut lui souhaiter de pire en
ce moment
d'avoir une vie de conte de fées quels
défauts aimeriez-vous avoir m menteuse
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir disponibles quels sont les
défauts que doit avoir un homme pour
vous séduire pervers qu'est-ce qui vous
donnerait envie d'être trompé par un
homme d'avoir du temps libre pendant
qu'il est pas là pour quelles raisons
seriez vous capable de refuser votre
plus belle histoire d'amour qu'elle me
rend heureuse qu'est-ce que vous n'avez
jamais dit à personne que je suis très
bien en tête à tête avec moi en quoi
aimeriez-vous être beaucoup plus nulle
en tir à la carabine qui ne voudriez
vous pas avoir comme femme oui oui
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir
ils m'ont dit ce qu'elle est le
compliment qui vous énerve le plus le
compliment de
dom qui a envie de me parler mais à qui
j'ai pas envie de parler
donc n'importe quel compliment qui vient
de quelqu'un à qui j'ai pas envie de
peindre
j'ai très bien coiffé sa quel est le
talent que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir
j'aimerais pas savoir lire des extraits
de mon livre savoir faire des lectures
de mon livre j'ai bien fait pas vous
demander de lire mais quel est le succès
littéraire que vous êtes content de ne
pas avoir écrit le petit prince
quelle phrase ne vous êtes vous jamais
je vais au fini
quelle est la phrase que vous aimeriez
ne pas avoir écrite alors oui c'est dans
le premier livre que j'ai écrit quand
j'avais à peu près 12 ans et c'est mes
larmes n'ont de cesse de couler un peu
l'eau par qui aimeriez-vous être détesté
par le héros de mon prochain roman
qu'est ce que vous aimeriez que
quelqu'un vous vole mon téléphone
portable
quelle est la mire mauvaises critiques
qu'on vous ait jamais faite
mon éditrice m'a dit un jour de creuser
la plaie mais ce qu'elle trouvait que
c'était pas assez creusé donc ça m'a
fait énormément avancé
quel est le mot que vous ne connaissez
pas que vous préférez
rosa room claire castillon vous parler
d'elle
voilà ben c'est pour ça qu'on va faire
une interview website d'art ariel
attention ariel qu'est ce qu'on peut
vous souhaiter de pire en ce moment en
ce moment pernet clés de ma bagnole ma
fille
[Applaudissements]
je dirais ben oui maman brûler les pieds
dans les fils du micro tomber sur celle
chose comme ça quels défauts
aimeriez-vous avoir d'être une heure par
jour invisible j'adorerais
alors comme je serai visible je pourrais
aller partout comme une petite souris
tout écouter tout voire invisible et
vous quels défauts aimeriez vous avoir
ouais ouais c'est pourquoi je devrais un
défaut je préfère ne pas imaginer
je lui réponds arial quelle est la
qualité que vous regrettez d'avoir
d'être parfois trop gentille ah oui
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait envie
d'être trompé mais si ça le rendait
heureux
voilà en quoi aimeriez-vous être
beaucoup plus nulle beaucoup plus mais
là j'ai déjà dit que j'étais nul en
orthographe mais beaucoup plus à quoi ça
servirait à rien qui ne voudriez vous
pas avoir comme fan alors justement dans
l'avion en revenant de sa lame un nom à
l'album
non mais mais il y avait courrier
international 1 et sur la couverture
il y avait vraiment des gens très très
désagréable des vrais fachos et ben euh
j'aimerais pas les avoir comme ainsi par
exemple ni pinochet ni milosevic me où
ça m'a bel laden
saddam hussein ni bonafi vais je les
aurais pas alors voilà quelle insulte
qui vous a fait le plus plaisir
highway l'état que wayne au texas c'est
quoi ça veut dire là oui c'est ça
c'était bonne là qu'est ce que vous
voudriez que votre mari rate balle
avions ont racheté avec moi qu'est ce
que vous lui interdisez que vous faites
vous même
je ne m'interdis rien rien donc sauf
justement de voir les mauvais signe que
je tourne parfois voilà quel est le rôle
que vous êtes content de ne pas avoir
joué
ah ben oui mais je vais pas dire du mal
de mes camarades
c'est un petit peu dans l'aérien bien ça
non le rôle que je suis contente de pas
avoir joué ben je suis contente de pas
avoir jouer l'autruche non jurassic park
et pourtant quelle belle phrase ne
dites-vous jamais je reviendrai à sanary
télé dont le trouble où je vous vois
apparaître et que me veulent dire et ses
soupirs pousser et ses sombres regard
que sur moi vous lancé que deux petites
les des loyauté dont le ciel est capable
avoue déloyauté n'ont rien de comparable
je suis resté tu sais quand même
voilà voilà une belle phrase que vous
dites jamais vu en espagnol ça se dit au
lac étale ses pions ramasser qu'est ce
que vous aimeriez ariel que quelqu'un
vole ça vole mon coeur quelle est la
meilleure mauvaises critiques qu'on vous
ait fait alors c'est dans le figaro elle
n'a rien au dessus du bikini est alors
oui je suis gay médusé et alors je me
suis posé la question malgré ce que je
devrais avoir un coeur une tête un
esprit des yeux ben non elle n'a rien au
dessus du but c'est marrant comme
auxquels ils mots que vous ne connaissez
pas que vous préférez akibag jusqu'au
bourg à se soulever travaux
d'économistes comme dark r d sur ma mère
et son bébé
tout est maintenant interdit aux eps
haidar
[Musique]
alors michel houellebecq qu'est ce qu'on
peut vous souhaiter de pire en ce moment
on sait sûrement gré des dents qui tombe
parce qu'elle avait un truc temporaire
et si c'est si ça tombe avant que j'aie
le temps de refaire un truc définitive
et je vais beaucoup merdé dans les
lectures ça va siffler je fais des
lectures en public j'adore ça la gueule
complément qui vous énerve le plus je
crois que c'est peut-être quand on me
dit que je suis gentil quelle est la
qualité que vous regrettez d'avoir assez
sûrement l'impossibilité de mentir parce
que moi ça m'a alors le carrément
littéraire moi sommes
qu'est-ce que j'en ai bavé dans les
émissions oui on est sommé de dire son
avis sur nos lives des autres on pense
du mal c'est horrible en écrivain
pardonne jamais un comme de démolition
public
quel est le talent que vous avez mais
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir longtemps
je me trouve trop intelligent jeu mais
c'est à dire que j'envisage trop de
possibilités quoi quels défauts aimeriez
vous avoir
je sais pas si c'est un défaut
j'aimerais bien de plus plus primaires
plus instinctif plus immédiat on dit que
vous êtes radin c'est vrai que non ça je
crois que c'est pas vrai ouais je sais
pas pourquoi on dit simplement de me
rappeler ce que vous dites que ces
paroles qui ne voudriez vous pas avoir
comme fans j'aimerais pas tellement voir
briller comme fans à bord ça me
maquiller très bon le nouveau roman vous
en pensez quoi
ensuite la merde ouais carrément
carrément il ne restera rien par qui
aimeriez-vous être détesté
mais j'aimerais bien que les écologistes
répondait aux agressions permanentes
sketches et j'aime pas tellement la
pensée écologiste ça me dégoûte un peu
mais j'ai beau agresser les écologistes
qui réagissent pas pourquoi ça me
dégoûte
parce que je suis resté très
baudelairien chercher tout ce qui est
naturel ou ne trouvent rien que d'offre
quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait c'est
peut-être une critique de julian barnes
sur plateforme way qui a dit quoi
en gros je fais je fais trop de
concession à l'émotion facile quoi je
perds un peu d'insolence bonnes
critiques
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour arriver à vous séduire
maladroite ça marche toujours moi je me
souviens une du bon en fait j'ai peur
j'ai pas du tout ça brise était une
histoire d'amour par la suite mais une
une stallone scott est la première fois
qu elle m'a vue était très ému de me
voir comme ce que je sais en hauteur
elle renversait carrément la bouteille
de vin sur moi je trouvais ça adorable
l'été l'an passé vous aimez juillet bon
ce qui a évidemment fanni s'est rien
passé
mais la maladresse mais ce qu'est ce que
l'avenir nous dira pas sur vous
on ne dira pas si j'ai été heureux ou
non ouais ça restera indécidable
jusqu'au bout ouais qu'est-ce que vous
n'avez jamais dit à personne et déjà je
vais tuer ouais parce que ce que je
pense que si je l'avais dit je l'aurais
fait est que j'ai eu envie mais mais non
j'ai l'intérêt l'interdît morale du
meurtre était le plus fort ouais
quelle est la question qu il ne faut pas
que je vous pose et se serait peut-être
qui je vais parce que j'ai pas ce que
j'aurais des réponses que j'ai envie
d'oublier
en fait j'ai envie d'être apaisé de
d'oublier jeu que je crois pas ou je
crois beaucoup au pardon c'est un
concept assez chrétien je peux ces
chrétiens mais j'ai envie de vous voyez
plus à l'oubli quand pardon oui
honnêtement oui et ça concernerait votre
mère par exemple ça pourrait milliers
d'autres personnes mais justement sur
les cuisses
n'en parlons pas merci président
remercie beaucoup michel est ce que vous
êtes prêts pour une interview et saïda
d'accord deux doigts
[Musique]
salman rushdie quels défauts aimeriez
vous avoir la cupidité quelle est la
qualité que vous regrettez d'avoir l'un
gentillesse qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait
envie d'être trompé par une femme au
caractère
qu'est ce que l'avenir nous le dira pas
sur hbo peut-être mon sens de l'humour
on ne sera jamais en quoi aimeriez-vous
être beaucoup plus mauvais un gars la
colère qui ne voudriez vous pas avoir
comme fans wa quels sont les défauts
qu'une femme doit avoir pour vous
séduire
la tolérance quelle est l'insulté qui
vous a fait le plus plaisir c'est la
portée par l'ayatollah comédie
quel est le complément qui vous énerve
le plus n'aimait pas le livre le
décrivez bien ce pays quel est le talon
que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir le talent
de d'intimider les quelle est la
question qu il ne faut pas que je vous
pose
je ne l'imposé pas qu'est ce que vous
aimeriez que quelqu'un vous volent
peut-être mon passé quelle est la
meilleure mauvaises critiques qu'on vous
ait fait my hand sonne mon fils une
femme a dit lors quand j'écris un livre
pour enfants qu'ils étaient trop lents
et que les gens pourrait s'ennuyer
alors je dirais écrit un rythme plus
rapide merci
salman rushdie ciani marc le clown c'est
publié chez plon mesdames messieurs
solaire ce qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter de pire en ce moment écoutez à
part la mort des gens que j'aime et ou
bien le fait que je sois atteint
brusquement d'une crise cardiaque
je crois que ce qui serait le pire c'est
la disparition brutale magique terrible
de tous mes livres dans toutes les
librairies
à l'heure actuelle oui je sais ça fait
quel des fous aimeriez vous avoir le
défaut que j'aimerais avoir je sais pas
peut-être peut-être la curiosité poussé
très loin parce que je manque ou
l'indiscrétion je ne l'est pas pour les
pas être animateur de télévision par
exemple il faudrait que je me force
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir je crois que ce sont quand même
or oui la courtoisie d'être courtois
ah oui parfois pas il est trop philippe
soit bien élevé des fois puis louis la
survie n'est ce pas tu vas oui mais
c'est votre côté 18e c'est la politesse
et pourtant je dis ce qui m ont à gagner
d'un cran
rien que dans un monde de brutes la
courtoisie vraiment qu'est-ce qui vous
aimerez envie d'être trompé par une
femme alors soit quel jeu des coûts
qu'elle préfère des imbéciles et
pourquoi pas ou alors qu'elle lit en
cachette des romans d'anna gavalda
en quoi aimeriez-vous être beaucoup plus
mauvais j'aimerais être plus mauvais en
méchanceté je n'arrive je n'y arrive pas
écrit non non je n'y arrive pas vraiment
j'aimerais être plus méchant c'est la
même chose que pour courtoisie et
franchement là je qu'elles sont quels
sont les défauts que doit avoir une
femme pour vous séduire
là c'est dans le livre c'est une fable
est séduisante à partir du moment où je
sens qu'elle est une bonne menteuse chez
l'étude bonne menteuse parce que
d'habitude
ah oui seulement bien entendu quand même
c'est pour lui est-ce qu'elle ment bien
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir
on s'est inquiété article c'était
merveilleux d'ailleurs rien de nouveau
sous le soleil ce et ça m'a plu quel est
le compliment qui vous énerve le plus
quand on dit que je suis brillant
intelligent cultivé
bon on vous le fera plus quel est le
talent que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir
j'aimerais pas avoir le
le don de galvaniser les foules
ouais parti pour l'instant tout va bien
parce que c'est très calme anisé pas
être ensemble
voilà par qui aimeriez-vous être détesté
eh bien je crois que je suis et je
depuis l'au delà
franchement c'est par françois
mitterrand voilà je jouais pas je n'aime
pas du tout ça a l'air pas du tout pas
du tout à dire laurent gerra la
concurrence
l'ami que vous n'aimeriez pas avoir ce
proche pour ben laden allaient ouais
ouais bon reconnaissez quand même tous
comment ça ça quel est le best-seller
que vous n'auriez pas aimé écrire alors
j'aurais bien aimé toucher l'argent de
davinci code mais pas le lait pas
l'écrire et comment faire voilà ce doux
joyau attention c'est la plus dure c'est
pourquoi j'ai la plus dure mois si vous
êtes le meilleur
pourquoi sa mère
alors
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter de
pire en ce moment que le réveil sonne et
qu'on me dise que tout ça n'était qu'un
rêve
ouais quels défauts aimeriez vous avoir
la rancune samarie that un peu rancunier
mais c'est aussi celui de nas avec
d'accord non savoir assez vite
quel est le cas l'encours vous
n'aimeriez pas avoir de talent je me
donner des ordres
ouais quelle est la qualité que vous
regrettez d'avoir tient les chiens de
ses interviews
je peux appeler ma femme la qualité
cassé c'est quoi la question la qualité
que vous regrettez d'avoir j'ai parfois
un peu trop consensuelle ouais
en quoi aimeriez-vous être beaucoup plus
mauvais beaucoup plus mauvais mais qui
pense qu'il est bon en tout je ne sais
pas je sais pas les interviews peut-être
peut-être
fan du samsah qui ne voudriez vous pas
avoir comme femme à alain paquet
ouais j'ai bien jeu
c'est bien ça va vous c'est vrai vous
vous engage directement prochaine
tournée non qui n'aimerait pas avoir
comme fan on va ya plein de gens qui me
vient à l'idée
tiens par exemple ghana par exemple si
par hasard si elle met un climat qui me
vient à l'esprit pas le borgne non mais
justement imagine imagine jean-marie en
train de chanter ya public
quels sont les défauts que doit avoir
une femme pour qu'elle vous séduisent
tous n'ont pas tous j'ai toujours peur
parce que je crois que là je reviens une
phrase que j'avais dit un jour comme ça
on m'a dit qu'avec négocier pour la
femme idéale j celle dont j'aimerais de
tous les défauts d'accord oui voilà
c'est ça celles dont les défauts me le
paraissent charmant et voilà jusqu'au
jour où ici le son - alors là c'est bien
qu'est-ce qui vous donnerait envie
d'être trompé par une femme ballon bon
que ça lui viennent à l'esprit
ça lui viennent à l'esprit au moment où
je sais pas comment la quitter voilà
avec leurs bonnes réponses quand avez
vous déjà été heureux d'être quitté par
bah quand j'étais plus amoureux comme
quand tous les hommes un peu lâche j'ai
laissé pourrir
quelle insulte qui vous a fait le plus
plaisir [ __ ] ouais bravo
quel est le compliment qui vous énerve
le plus c'est ce qui est arrivé il ya
pas longtemps dans un aéroport
c'est
j'adore vos chansons monsieur jacques
brel ouais très bien sauté du commun le
mec
j'aime ça aussi avec francis cabrel
qu'est ce que vous voudriez que vos
enfants rate beaucoup de choses pour que
pour qu'ils aient la la la notion de
l'échec pour pouvoir apprécier mieux le
l'éventuel succès enfin je sais pas si
c'est très clair je te dis tu es oui
vous avez plusieurs la troisième guerre
mondiale
ah ouais ouais la troisième guerre
c'est vrai aussi ah c'est vous qui aimez
vous détestez
je vais vous détestez ouais laurent ok
si si si si les noms les gars avec qui
je joue au poker mais voilà d'accord ça
ça je sais les seuls moments où on peut
aimer détester quelqu'un
ouais parce que dans la relation on est
obligé de de tester quelqu'un qui en
face de vous quand on veut quand on veut
gagner par qui aimeriez-vous et détesté
détesté par une femme parce qu'il paraît
que c'est un signe ah ouais vous dire
sans raison quelqu'un qui déteste comme
ça sans raison
ça peut être un signe de grande
excitation chez au terrain gelé quelle
récompense que vous avez reçue qui ne
vous honore pas 3 [ __ ] c'est super dur
quelle est leur récompense que j'ai
reçus te mords pas veille à 3 négation
contre la population mais il va voir
faut avoir fait huit ans de psychanalyse
et d'avoir été gardé ce qu'on a pu taper
la francisque
non il ya une récompense qui nous honore
pas oui les cris des femmes qui ont
simulé ah bravo
regardez ça m'étonnerait ceci étant ça
méchamment et qu on simule avait bien
sont là
quelle est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques qu'on vous ait fait meilleur
mauvaises critiques meilleur mauvaise
critique
tu vas voir c'est la meilleure mauvaises
critiques
c'est un chanteur populaire
ah ouais ouais peut-être est la pire
bonnes critiques
la pire bonnes critiques c'est celle que
les gens vous font dans une loge quand
ils viennent voir au théâtre et qui vous
disent tu été formidable mais c'est un
rôle en or
ah ouais d'accord c'est terry parce que
l'euroland n'ya pas alors c'est qu'on
l'a bien fait et tu peux rien répond tu
fais ces abrutis
quel est votre plus belle erreur de
croire que tout est possible et votre
pire victoire c'est d'avoir de n'avoir
pas chanter dans les villes front
national et de penser aujourd'hui que
j'ai eu raison
[Musique]
alors maintenant il ya un truc très dur
qui vous attend quoi
vous commencez tout le monde en parle
faut que ça se paye vous allez voir une
interview de terribles l'interview
lapierre l'interview upside down
attention qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter de pire en ce moment patrick
que la jungle se plante
quels défauts aimeriez-vous avoir volé
voleur par une gomme j'arrive pas à
voler sur donc
ah ouais ça n'a pas d'intérêt non mais
ça me rend malade non mais l'idée de
voler un truc qui me rend malade
j'aimerais parfois vole un oeuf déjà
vous allez par paliers tu m'entends gay
quelle est la qualité que vous regrettez
d'avoir crédules crois je crois
malheureusement beaucoup je crois
beaucoup à l'eau aux gens et à ce qu'on
peut me direz par exemple sur la jungle
matthieu delaporte le savez ça et me
faisait croire m'a dit il ya un acteur
gérald laroche qui est formidable dans
le film qui fait loppsi on dit faut que
tu fasse gaffe à pas parler de l'
affaire grégory des blacks c'est le
frère de bernard laroche
et quand il est arrivé la première fois
je le regardais beaucoup de compassion
et voilà donc j'aimerais de la bulle
ouais ouais qu'est-ce que vous n'avez
jamais dit à personne
tu suces ouais t'es jamais dit ça mais
oui avec s'il te plait je veux tu s'il
te plaît mais tu suces tous les six mois
en mois voilà et sucé halope encore
moins moi c'est celle du doigt des idées
reçues c'est général ouais tous sexes
confondus il a pas dit le général
est ce que je suis c'est tromper mon
dieu c'est vrai
alors est ce que c'est ça les requins
salon ces regards qui m'avait demandé
qui ne voudriez vous pas avoir comme
fans dominique de villepin en ce moment
ne déride il faudra aller voir l'agenda
déjà à l entrée c'est pas lisse et ça
marche très mauvaise idée
la ville veut flinguer un film qu'il
passerait pas qu'ils en parlent quels
sont les défauts que doit avoir une
femme pour qu'elle vous séduisent
qu'elle soit plus grande que moi quelle
insulte qui vous a fait le plus plaisir
quand je jouais chico et une fois un mec
qui m'a dit aux producteurs qui m'a dit
tu en as pas marre de faire ta p'tite
[ __ ] brésilienne ouais donc voilà je
trouve ça classe puisque [ __ ] sais pas
non ces bases il ya là et et petit oui
senna sait pas quel compliment qui vous
énerve le plus quand un mec arrive tu
l'as pas vu depuis dix ans et qui fait
ta pas changé ouais ça c'est très
énervant non mais j'ai envie de changer
donc tu préfère qu'on dise oh la la
qu'est ce que tu as pris lyon oui par
exemple moi je préfère je vous trouve
mieux maintenant qu'il ya dix ans et le
côté les gens tapent à changer saisir
ivoirien quoi je te regarde moi survie
mais d'où te vient cette joie de vivre
guy parce que c'est communicatif un
incroyable talent électrisé le public la
somme mignot quelle est la meilleure
mauvaises critiques qu'on vous ait fait
la meilleure mauvaises critiques bien
écrite quoi ou pas écrite par quelqu'un
qu'on respecte vaguement mes moyens mais
qu'avait dit renaud matignon dans le
figaro quand j'ai commencé la télé il
avait dit ardisson arrive du néant et
après deux heures de plus il y retourne
c'est super c'est super bien écris tu
peux rien dire ah oui c'était donc mon
père ce héros à l'époque de mon père ce
héros est un journal qui s'appelait
guêpier sais pas s'il existe toujours
le journal la petite [ __ ] pas
et qui disait pourtant nous verserons ce
film n'a vraiment aucun intérêt si ce
n'est l'acteur patrick pan pan dans le
mille aulas quel talent
[Musique]